>> From the Library of
Congress in Washington DC.
>> JOANNA PECORE: Hi, I'm
Joanna Pecore and I'm here
with some Cambodian
musicians and dancers.
Master Chum Ngek, Madam Sam-Oeun
Tes, Bonavy Chhim and Sovann Chum.
And I just want to introduce them,
and have them introduce
themselves a little bit.
So, can you, let's see
Necru how about you tell me
about your history as a dancer.
>> SAM-OUEN TES: Okay.
My name ...
Joanna already told, my name
is Sam-Oeun Tes [inaudible].
I came into United States
in 1970, and I was taught
in Royal Palace in Cambodia.
I came into United States in 1970;
start teaching dance
over here, 1972.
And we start growing
until we come to a group.
19 ... Cambodian American
Heritage born in 1980.
>> JOANNA PECORE: Okay.
Nice. How about Chum
Ngek, Master Chum.
>> CHUM NGEK: My name Chum Ngek.
I'm the, live in Cambodia from 1939,
I came to United States in 1982,
and I start to teach new things.
After five years later, I
start to teach music at home.
I'm go to help American
Heritage, and play together
and go together and
performing in 2004.
I have art endowment and start to
learn music in like 10 years old,
in Cambodia with my grandfather.
My grandfather is the
name [inaudible],
but I start with the Master
[inaudible], Master Tong,
Master Chu, Master
Chum, and Master ...
A lot of the teacher
[inaudible], the last one.
I start to play in group in Cambodia
with my group and another group
and go to performing
in University Fine Art.
In 1982, and I go back to my
home to help my grandfather
and he is not feeling good.
I cannot go back to him again.
>> JOANNA PECORE: I see.
Okay. Bonavy, you've been
dancing for a while now, too.
How did you get into the dance?
>> BONAVY CHHIM: My aunt.
She forced all of us
when we were kids.
But, somehow I stuck with it because
I enjoy the traditional dance.
Also, it helps me to learn
about my heritage because I came
to the United States in '82.
I went through the
civil war of Pol Pot.
When I came to the United States
with my mom and my aunt at age
of nine years old, so then to
learn about my own arts heritage.
It was through dance, different
characters that I learned
from different teachers
through the years.
I learned about, I would
say, 33 years as in training
in Cambodian classical dance.
But, I became a junior teacher in
year 2000 and now I do instruction
with the different character:
giant, female role, male role.
But, my best character
that I enjoy is the giant.
It's a very powerful role.
But it's just my body is so small,
that I still like the
giant role the best.
Just has so much power and moves,
so I enjoy the Cambodian
traditional dance very much.
>> JOANNA PECORE: You're
like a Master almost by now.
>> BONAVY CHHIM: I'm 50% there.
Even though I've been in the
program for 30-something years,
I'm just halfway there because
compared to the students
at the University of
Fine Art in Cambodia,
because they train every day;
whereas when in the United State,
we don't have that opportunity.
So, when we train,
we train only Sundays
and it's not even all year round
because we don't have that funding
for the program for year-round.
So, we're able to train and when
I visit home, I'm able to train
from the Master teacher
from the Royal Palace.
So, I have together about 10 Master
teachers, different characters,
different technique,
and I enjoy that.
>> JOANNA PECORE: How about your
history as a musician, Sovann?
>> SOVANN CHUM: I started playing
music when I was I guess, three.
At five years old, I was playing
at Carnegie Hall in New York.
That was my first show
playing the drums.
I got into playing music
because of my father, of course.
Kind of forced in the
beginning, which was okay.
It helped me cultivate my culture,
understand my culture, my language.
It was a great opportunity.
So, I kind of developed my skill of
liking playing music after a while.
It comes natural to me.
I can play basically any
instrument that's in front of me.
Now, it's just a passion, it's just
hobby to do and I really enjoy it.
It makes my father happy, so
that's always a good thing.
He taught us well,
as my sister as well.
She also plays music as well.
So, as of right now I don't
have any other teachers.
I only had one Master
teacher and that's my father.
He's a great mentor and
I look up to him a lot.
I wouldn't be where
I'm at without him.
I appreciate everything he did
and all the awards that he won.
As a professional Master musician,
I'm really, really happy for that.
>> JOANNA PECORE: Necru, what was it
like to learn the Cambodian dance?
What was your experience like
learning Cambodian dance?
>> SAM-OUEN TES: Yes, it's
very, very hard; difficult.
I was trained the first time in
Cambodia in Royal in Phnom Penh.
I have aunt that she Master
teacher of the male role.
She take me over there and I'm
not really quite that I'm sure
that I like, but that day
somehows they take that ...
We go with her and she sit
down, watch the movement
of all the student dance.
Somehow come the music,
it's go to your ear.
It's just like [Khmer], mean like
something coming to your mind.
I'm go back home and my
aunt asked me, "Do you like?
Do go tomorrow?
Go back tomorrow?"
I say, "Yes."
I was 14 years old.
It's [inaudible], it's teenager.
It's hard to move, flexible.
My body was so soft, too soft.
The teacher tried to
straight my body,
make it strong, because
too flexible.
>> JOANNA PECORE: Oh gosh.
>> SAM-OUEN TES: But, it is hard.
It's very hard; difficult.
The next day, I get [inaudible] and
I have long hair, and then dress
up like [inaudible],
and start dance.
It's just come like this.
>> JOANNA PECORE: Overnight?
>> SAM-OUEN TES: Yeah.
It's overnight.
I never think about I can dance.
My sister, the middle sister,
she's learning every
Sunday and every Thursday.
They take from the, pick any student
they like to learn classical dance
or the different class, different
school, they came in every Thursday.
But me? Never thinking I'm
going to go learn, but this,
I don't know it's just coming to me.
We start and I have 10, 12 teacher.
I can go any play with
all the teenager, no.
Finish all teacher came in,
push, cut, got and I got you,
you know it's a movement.
One push me to learn
quickly so can go to the ...
with the first group.
You have first group, the leader,
the middle group, and
the third group.
I'm on the middle group.
She want to push me harder
to go to first group.
My leg was like this.
Shake. The first I dance
in Siem Reap, first time.
I will learn on three month only.
Three months, I will
dance in Siem Reap
and my skirt was just
shake like this.
So, depend on the teacher.
If your teacher love
you, really you go.
If the teacher don't
really like you,
you on the backstage,
I'm sorry to say that.
I'm really to say ...
>> JOANNA PECORE: That's
how it works.
>> SAM-OUEN TES: It is.
This is the way they do in Palace.
It's really strict.
You beautiful, you good,
you flexible, you smart.
They push you quick.
It's not mean on the
back they is not smart.
Just the way the teacher
like, the love.
>> JOANNA PECORE: Yeah,
she pay attention to you.
>> SAM-OUEN TES: Pay attention
to you, you can go quickly.
I dance for the President,
other president
in different country,
go there in [inaudible].
I was learning not quite six month,
so shake, but it's not for anything.
It's just scared to death.
>> JOANNA PECORE: On the inside.
>> SAM-OUEN TES: Yes, inside.
After that, the butterfly is gone.
It came into United State and
just like, Necru, a lot of teacher
like [inaudible], and [inaudible].
She's come and join with us.
We glad that work out
to get a big group.
It's very, very difficult.
It's not easy to build a
big group, it's not easy.
You have to know how
to pull a suitcase.
I told my niece, you become the
teacher or Master teacher they call,
you have to know how to pull
the suitcase out, sewing,
put the crown on, be sure
all the kid was learning,
be sure the kid had the
food to eat, everything.
Your mind is ...
It's not easy.
>> JOANNA PECORE: More than dancing.
>> SAM-OUEN TES: Yes.
Become to the large
group, like 50 student.
It's not easy to know.
Now I'm try to retire and pass
to another teacher or my niece,
who is strong enough to do it.
I [inaudible], she's not here, but
I still say to the cameras say,
thank you for her help all
this time, right Necru?
We work out.
[inaudible] myself, it would work.
I build from scratch, no
money, no nothing, two feet,
two hand, singer, everything.
We don't need Necru yet.
After that, it's come to large group
and then we invite
Necru to get the money.
Please, anybody can hear
for me about the grant.
We don't have two years for grant.
Anything help for Cambodian
American Heritage
to success to reserve a culture.
>> JOANNA PECORE: So, the
organization has been going
on for more than 30 years now?
>> SAM-OUEN TES: Yes.
Over 30 year since 1980.
Now it's year 2017,
so how many year?
37.
>> JOANNA PECORE: Almost
40 years now.
>> SAM-OUEN TES: Yeah, almost 40.
>> JOANNA PECORE: Yeah,
it's been going strong-
>> SAM-OUEN TES: Yes.
>> JOANNA PECORE: -and
now the funding,
because you're non-profit,
it's going down.
>> SAM-OUEN TES: Please go up.
>> JOANNA PECORE: Yeah, yeah.
>> SAM-OUEN TES: I have
a website, you know.
>> JOANNA PECORE: Yeah.
>> SAM-OUEN TES: Call us.
Joanna, thank you for you, too.
You help us all this year.
Thank you all the student, all
the crew, and Sovann, my niece.
I never forget my life.
I have award, but it's
award for my name,
but it's go to Cambodian American
Heritage and all of Cambodian art.
That's all I can say.
>> JOANNA PECORE: So, Necru you
mentioned you had a lot of teachers.
What did you study
with your teachers?
What instruments do you play?
>> CHUM NGEK: The first thing
I start to play [inaudible]
with my grandfather, but
before I start to play
and I think I'm five
years old or something.
You know the call, the percussion.
I just play and take off from
the back, my grandfather.
When he performing, we
couldn't find the [inaudible].
Say, "Who took [inaudible]?"
Took it, forgot to put it back.
Later time he come and he find, he
ask me, "You like to play music?"
I say, "Yeah, I like to play it."
All the time when my
grandfather taught the music,
my house we had two level.
The one level downstair [inaudible]
here we don't have basement.
Downstair we have the whole thing.
I play up-ground and downstair.
I have stick, chopstick and when my
grandfather taught music upstair,
I just play with the chopstick.
After that, he asked me,
"You like playing music?"
I say, "Yeah."
"You like to play music, when
you start you cannot quit."
I say, "Yeah, I promise."
I start to play around 10 years old.
I start to learn music from him.
The first thing I play called ...
The first song, second song,
but you know, it pulls me a lot
in the morning, early morning.
The water in my country, the cold,
in the mornings is very cold.
He didn't say anything to me.
He call me in the early morning
around four o'clock in the morning.
You know the kid, four
o'clock they want to wake up.
They want to sleep, but wake up.
I say, "No, I want to sleep a
little bit before go to school."
He say, "No, you promise
you want to learn music.
You supposed to wake up early
morning before you go to school."
I wake up in the morning.
He told me, "Go to the river and-
>> JOANNA PECORE: The river.
>> CHUM NGEK: The lake,
something like that.
We have the water, but
he didn't say anything.
He push me like-
>> JOANNA PECORE: Kicked you?
>> CHUM NGEK: He push me, kick
me like that in the water.
I say, "What happen?"
He didn't say anything because
you know he didn't explain to me
about what they do
for the learn music.
>> JOANNA PECORE: Kicking you.
>> CHUM NGEK: When go hit
water, my leg is cold.
It was like ...
something like that.
The later time I learned he
explain to me why I do like that.
I don't want you to know anything
about, I push you in the water.
The water, the cold.
The cold, you supposed
to do like that.
Music people, we need hand-
>> JOANNA PECORE: Flexible.
>> CHUM NGEK: -movement.
Yeah. After that, he
tell me to go to-
>> SAM-OUEN TES: That's a good idea.
>> CHUM NGEK: -learn
of take from the water.
Call it ...
I forgot the name in the ...
>> SAM-OUEN TES: Grass.
Lemongrass.
[crosstalk].
>> CHUM NGEK: Grass.
Lemongrass.
Yeah, he took from lemongrass.
He put my arm.
He put my arm something like that.
After that, he goes me to
learn in xylophone [inaudible].
And the first time,
we don't put the time.
The time clock, no.
He put the tube, you
know the tube piece?
>> JOANNA PECORE: Incense stick.
>> CHUM NGEK: He put like
this one, two, three.
>> JOANNA PECORE: He marked it.
>> CHUM NGEK: The first
time he put like the,
when the coming stopped it.
The next day they put like this
and the second day
they put all one tube.
He wanted to play xylophone like
that, because the first song,
they wanted me to [inaudible]
and play almost I think,
maybe half hour.
>> JOANNA PECORE: That's a lot.
>> CHUM NGEK: A lot, no stop.
>> JOANNA PECORE: Oh wow.
>> CHUM NGEK: They
make me and after that,
[inaudible] Master
teacher for [inaudible].
My grandfather, he know
everything about instrument.
They want to invite special people,
the Master people to learn the ...
learn for the xylophone.
I have a lot of teacher,
you ask me, right?
We have every instrument,
we had Master teacher.
I say, "Why?
You know everything, why you
didn't taught me the whole thing?
Why you invited people
to taught me?"
He said, "No, a lot of people,
we have special people to play.
[inaudible] is professional
for [inaudible].
[inaudible], he's professional
Master ...
I forgot the name-
>> JOANNA PECORE: Ton?
>> CHUM NGEK: Yeah Ton.
We have a lot of different teachers.
Every instrument, we
have one teacher.
Every instrument, one teacher.
When I start to play,
really different.
It's not from one teacher.
We have a lot of teachers.
We have a lot of idea.
They explain to me, this one, that
song you supposed to play like this,
but another teacher [inaudible]
"You supposed to play this way."
Another teacher told me, "This way."
A lot of teacher, but I have a
lot of way [inaudible] is the way,
we have a lot of way to
play for the good music.
Until I play around in
Cambodia, I travel a lot.
If not, stay home.
Every man came home like at 2:00,
3:00, after the school came from.
I go around.
>> JOANNA PECORE: It didn't confuse
you all the different teachers
telling you different things?
>> CHUM NGEK: No, not confuse.
Explain small thing,
it's not very different.
A little different just
in the way they play.
Every teacher they
know all instrument.
>> JOANNA PECORE: The basics.
>> CHUM NGEK: But, the special,
the one special [inaudible]...
I forgot the name of that-
>> JOANNA PECORE: [inaudible].
>> CHUM NGEK: [inaudible], he's
the best one of the [inaudible].
In Cambodia, the best
one [inaudible].
I don't want to play the
[inaudible] the easy way,
but my grandfather know, we
need you to play [inaudible].
>> JOANNA PECORE: Wow.
That's a lot.
Bonavy, what makes you continue?
What motivates you to keep dancing?
>> BONAVY CHHIM: Well, growing up
in America going to public school,
they don't really teach you
about Cambodia, the heritage.
All you know is the poverty
of Cambodia and the war.
They don't know the arts.
So, as I was learning and
performing with different community.
Then I thought to myself,
if you don't preserve your heritage
the other generation will not know
about their heritage at all.
I'm grateful for my
aunt and Lacru to ...
Even though they are in America,
they still preserve their heritage
so that the generation
after us, they will know
about what Cambodia is about.
Cambodian traditional dance,
it's the national dance,
the national arts for Cambodia.
I follow everybody
at the University.
I follow the teachers on Facebook
because they train every day.
Their skills is so, they
have perfect the art so well.
Every detail and when I follow
them I look at their training
and when I do have the opportunity
to go home, I'm able to go
and ask them for help because
every teacher has their specialty
in a specific role, but they
have different technique,
so if you are able to get
their talent, their technique
and incorporate into yourself,
then you would be a better dancer.
So, even though I've been in
the program for over 30 years
in dancing the same dance,
but I'm still 50% there.
So, I don't think I will be
able to achieve Master teacher
yet until I'm able to
learn the other skills.
And I try to do my best, but
I know there's certain things
that I lack in the arts.
But, I still consider
myself as a student as well
as teaching my next generation.
It's very important.
I was telling a few people
here, Americans, the public,
young children, I was
able I think, a month ago,
I was able to visit
a elementary school.
A third grade class that invited
me to do some demonstration.
And it was at a urban
city public school.
Just because I'm just dressed like
this, they thought it was amazing.
They have never seen and they never
know about Cambodian arts at all.
All they know, they
had so many questions
for me and I was so surprised.
They had it in their card and
they asked specific questions.
And it was amazing.
Even though, whether
you're Cambodian or American
or any generation, any children,
you need to preserve your heritage.
And we need to keep continuing.
The arts, music, dance; that's
part of what human being is about
and different ethnic group has their
own heritage, their own culture.
And even if you live in a different
country, you still bring yourself
from where you're born
into where you're going.
And if you don't know that
from where you're from,
then you're lacking something.
So, in order for you to be a whole
as a person, you need to know
where you're from, your history.
Whether you're American
or Cambodian or any,
you need to know your history,
you need to preserve that.
You need to pass it on to the next
generation, so they don't forget
and they can be a whole person.
So, that's why we continue,
we push the other kids.
Sometimes as a young person, you
may not want to be part of it
and you get pushed by your
grandmother or mother or something
like that, and you do it.
Some people might not like it,
some people might feel that,
oh maybe this is something
that I want to do.
That was me.
Out of my cousins, I still
stuck with the dance.
It was all of us, everybody,
boy and girl.
All of us, she push us.
Every year we had to
come in and get trained.
But, all my other cousins,
they stop,
but for me, I think it's part of me.
I'm just so eager to learn and I'm
always following different videos.
When I see the Master teacher,
I mean, they're so great.
Even at a 80 year old, I seen one
of the teacher that does giant,
she's so strong when
she do her move.
Even though at her age, is like
when you see her it's like, "Wow,
I can't even get like that."
It's in your build-up.
Since you practice so long and
doesn't matter if you have it.
If you have the structure,
no matter how old you get,
you still can do those moves.
You might not be able
to do one leg up,
but you can still see
the broad shoulder
and the exact detail of the move.
I follow them.
She has no teeth, but she still do
the move and the giant is so ...
I was like, "Oh my god."
I show to my student, too.
I was like, "Look at her,
she's so strong at her age."
>> SAM-OUEN TES: Tell
them [inaudible].
>> BONAVY CHHIM: [inaudible],
and then the one
that taught me is [inaudible].
She's amazing.
>> SAM-OUEN TES: [inaudible].
>> BONAVY CHHIM: [inaudible], and
then [inaudible], and [inaudible],
[inaudible], my aunt,
and [inaudible].
I have so many teachers.
I always want to learn from them.
It's certain detail.
It's like, you look at one teacher,
and then she does the smile,
the gesture differently, and then
you learn from somewhere else,
and it just all together.
You just incorporate to your own.
>> JOANNA PECORE: It
becomes a part of you, yeah.
>> BONAVY CHHIM: Exactly.
>> SAM-OUEN TES: The movement
is a little bit different.
It's much the same, it's just the
way they push you, strong or light.
>> JOANNA PECORE: It's
a personal touch to ...
>> SAM-OUEN TES: The way they move.
>> JOANNA PECORE: Wow.
>> SAM-OUEN TES: The
technique is classical dance.
It's really, really hard.
>> BONAVY CHHIM: Have to be precise.
>> SAM-OUEN TES: If one teacher
push you, you have to stick that.
If another one come
in, you have to follow.
You have to use your mind, too.
Which one you want to choose?
It's like my aunt, my Master ...
She's [inaudible].
She is just like a king.
If she come in dance,
she is like a man.
It's a king.
It's just like ...
>> JOANNA PECORE: Wow.
>> SAM-OUEN TES: You can watch
her down a chair with her.
You can see, she is a king.
She act like that.
She's like that.
She's like [inaudible],
she's a female dance.
She's Master female dance.
My aunt is female for
Master male role.
She's both [inaudible],
a love story.
It just like exactly
like you've just...
>> JOANNA PECORE: Perfect.
>> BONAVY CHHIM: The real thing.
>> JOANNA PECORE: They motivate you
to do better because
they're so good.
>> BONAVY CHHIM: The character
because in traditional
dance, it's a sign language.
It tells a story, so without
the moves, with the gesture,
with your finger, your body, it
tells a story so that the audience,
if they're watching and they may
not understand Cambodian language
or what the lyrics is about,
but they can tell the
story based on the move.
So, if that role is supposed
to be a king or a prince,
and we're doing a scene that we're
going to battle with the giant
or the soldier is sitting
and waiting for the order,
if you're the king, when you
demonstrate your power in the shape
of your body, in your expression,
in your move, it all go together
to tell a story of
that particular role.
So that the audience can see
and say, "I understand what
that person is doing,
because it demonstrate that,
that gesture so perfectly."
So, that's why it takes
years of training,
so it's like if you do a principal
character, you don't just jump
and perform the next day.
It takes training and
preparation from years,
and years, and years to be perfect.
In traditional dance, it's precise.
Every move tells a story.
Every gesture tells
a story; expression.
It takes a lot of year of training
and skill to put into that.
>> JOANNA PECORE: That's
why it's hard.
>> BONAVY CHHIM: Difficult.
It is.
>> JOANNA PECORE: Yeah,
to master it.
Wow. Okay finally, Sovann,
can you explain what it's
like to learn from your father?
What's your experience
studying music?
>> SOVANN CHUM: It's kind of hard,
because I haven't had
any other teachers.
Like my father said and all
[inaudible] and Bonavy said, it's,
a lot of people learn
from a lot of Masters.
Yes, a lot of the Masters
can play all the instruments,
but not all of them can
master one instrument.
The benefit of me is that my father
can master every single instrument.
That what makes me great, I
guess, and a passion of it.
I enjoy going different venues,
playing different arenas,
different areas.
I don't have butterflies,
even when I was a little kid.
It just came so natural to me.
I just enjoyed it so much.
It's very great.
It's an honor to actually learn
from someone who knows how
to play every instrument and
actually master every instrument.
So, I guess I consider myself lucky.
>> JOANNA PECORE: Yeah,
I would think so.
>> SOVANN CHUM: Very lucky.
>> JOANNA PECORE: Very lucky.
>> SOVANN CHUM: I listen to
other Master teachers play
and they actually want
to learn from me.
They actually want
to learn how I do it.
To hear from other
Master teachers...
because the way we play music
is not any other culture,
any other way because
they play with notes.
Us, it's all by memorizing
everything.
That's the hardest part.
Every teacher has a different
way of playing, their way.
My father have a unique
way of playing his style.
Everyone loves and learns from
him, listens to his CDs and stuff.
The benefit of me is, I cannot play
music for a year or two, come back
and it's right there again.
I guess, it is a great opportunity
and I'm very fortunate and lucky
to have him as a teacher.
>> JOANNA PECORE: It's very nice.
Thank you-
>> SAM-OUEN TES: I
just wanted to add-
>> JOANNA PECORE: Add something.
>> SAM-OUEN TES: -one more ...
I have to thanks to, I think
she passed away already.
That's a long time with Pol Pot,
so I just let them know that thanks
to her that's teach me how to dance
and now I came to United States,
build a group and [inaudible],
[inaudible], [inaudible].
I was taught, I was the [inaudible].
I came to United States,
I'm the taller one,
so then become male role.
I can dance both male
role and female role.
[inaudible], [inaudible],
[inaudible], [inaudible] ...
[inaudible].
A lot of [inaudible].
So, thank you that's
she been taught us.
I have ...
all kind came into pass
around to this generation.
>> JOANNA PECORE: In
the United States.
It's wonderful.
>> SAM-OUEN TES: Thank you so much.
>> JOANNA PECORE: Thank you.
>> SOVANN CHUM: Same here.
I would like to thank my
grandfather, my great-grandfather,
absolutely that taught
my father everything.
I guess without my great-grandfather
teaching my father,
things would have been probably
different, during the Khmer Rouge.
He survived a lot because of the
ability to play music, coming here,
the awards that he have won.
I would definitely like to thank
my great-grandfather for passing
down that tradition, the arts,
making everyone a better person here
to preserve the culture that's
been lost during the war.
So, I would like to thank all
the teachers that passed away
and everyone that tried
to keep this alive.
It's very important.
>> JOANNA PECORE: Thank
you everybody.
>> SAM-OUEN TES: Okay, that's all.
>> JOANNA PECORE: Thank you for
you beautiful performance today.
>> BONAVY CHHIM: Thank you.
>> SOVANN CHUM: Thank you.
>> SAM-OUEN TES: Thank you.
>> SOVANN CHUM: Appreciate it.
>> This has been a presentation
of the Library of Congress.
Visit us at loc dot gov.